personne n'aime être né avec fougue le
nouveau star wars met fin à la saga des
skywalker amorcé en 1977 sous la tutelle
de joker jamais aucune légende
il avait été acquis tant que cette
épopée du futur encore une fois ça
brasse pas mal dans la galaxie le
seigneur palpatine qui avait été jeté
dans un gros trou dans l'épisode 6
revient dans cet épisode 9 plus méchant
que jamais j'ai en tout cas c'est dans
ses habitudes
palpatine woeth anéantir une fois pour
toutes les rebelles et la jeune reine
l'éternel dilemme cornélien chara la
franchise est toujours là l'héroïne à la
force mais son bord at-elle vers le côté
obscur
dans cette lutte entre le bien et le mal
il y à de multiples rebondissements et
de très très grande révélation
on apprend que le père de ré est en fait
je ne vais quand même pas tout vous
déballez mais je peux vous dire que les
effets spéciaux sur fond d'écran vert
sont impressionnants il y à de l'action
à souhait et les nostalgiques vont
verser quelques larmes garantie il y à
du moment émouvant pour ceux et celles
qui ont su garder leur coeur d'enfant je
regarde une dernière fois
mais année malgré quelques faiblesses et
un scénario parfois simple il est bon ce
dernier star wars
toutes ces sections apprécié des fans un
film réussi selon deux grands fans jeff
bérard et mc gilles fallu faire plaisir
à tout le monde en matière de prêts tous
les personnages et toutes les situations
mais faire une histoire cohérente là
dedans
dans les circonstances c'est un bon film
du médecin mais on veut faire plaisir
beaucoup beaucoup à tout le monde
pour moi ça a été une réussite
présentement la sortie de là avec un
sourire un visage c'était c'était
divertissant par même temps se
répondaient à plein question qu'on a eu
dans cette trilogie le kit eco répondu
je donne quatre étoiles sur 5 à ce style
wars et vous moi je fais la sédition
j'aimerais un beau 3.5 est ce que pour
moi c'est généreux 3.5
c'est une très très bonne moyenne j'ai
pleuré sûr c'est que je vais le donner 4
dont 80 pour ça c'est bon à l'école de
la force sur avec
toujours ici louis philippe ouimet radio
canada montréal
[Musique]